did anyone approach you to do the remix
i'm not some of the actual like chris
brown or popcorn but where there's like
people who hit you trying to do a remix
yeah hell yeah the whole industry
musicians so that's what's far back yeah
it's like the whole industry like kind
of saved the vibes under so like um fab
did a remix um
hey vibro from tory cranium
um
jaded kingdom
busta rhymes like it's it got create a
boogie did a remix and these favi
like the list is low-key kind of crazy
people we're not they're all just their
own remixes just like yo if you're a dj
just pick which makes you like the most
yeah it's like a yeah it's like a
collectible or something like that so
like the different djs are playing it in
different regions they're playing
different different regions what's the
biggest biggest remix it's not the
official remix
you think the biggest as far as like
what you hear the most when you're out
i'm not gonna i can't even do that
because there's like if i go certain
places like certain cities they're only
gonna play like
certain like this you go certain places
they're only gonna play the a boogie one
and like the french montana one that's
in the safe there's gotta be a french
one i didn't know there was a freaking
crazy one
yeah shout out to french yes sir you tap
jim roy woods every bro is
crazy